this is one of the biggest sunscreen  myths that spf 50 is only one percent  more protective than spf 30. this myth  is based on the fact that spf 50 blocks  98 of uv while spf 30 blocks about 97  but we don't care about the uv that we  don't get we care about the uv that  actually gets through and hits our skin  so actually this pink section svr30 lets  in three point three percent spf 50 less  than two percent that means spf 30 lets  in more than one and a half times as  much uv spf 50 is one and a half times  more protective and this is what we see  in studies people who use higher spf end  up with less sunburn so don't overthink  it just look at the spf number your  protection is proportional to that